for the policing Minister Chris philp
joins me now a very good morning to you
thanks so much for coming in good
morning let's
not with that report
um children as young as nine running
drugs for gangs thousands of young
people in England being groomed harmed
or even killed how has this been allowed
to happen and get worse under your watch
well uh I've been in the job for about a
week this is yeah this is a matter
that's of deep concern it has been for
some years so in 2019 three years ago a
whole initiative was launched to tackle
this County Line's problem whereas your
report really powerfully set out
Children very young children often are
being groomed and exploited there are
four priority areas where money has been
invested that's London uh greater
Manchester merseyside and the West
Midlands in particular 145 million
pounds was put against this task and as
a result of that 2 400 county lines
operations have been dismantled and
there have been 8 000 arrests so a huge
amount of work has been done here
there's a coordination Center to make
sure that we're coordinating nationally
because obviously these county lines by
by their very nature cross police force
areas for example you might have a gang
in London for instance running drugs
down to the South Coast to Coastal
communities so it runs across police
force boundaries that's why the
coordination is so important there's a
lot of work going on here over the last
three years in particular both with
money and with police officer resource
that is delivering results those 8 000
arrests are making a real difference but
there clearly is a lot more work to do
well yes I mean you say results but
these are startling facts that children
that young are getting involved and
caught up in these gangs and the report
says that there are already huge
stresses on over stretched Services they
they suggest that any return to
austerity would be a gift to those who
exploit children yet we have warnings of
course from the chancellor that spending
cuts are needed to balance the book so
will the necessary budgets be protected
in this spending review well obviously
we need to wait and see what the
chancellor says on the 17th of November
but I would expect as the chancellor
this makes it decisions in the coming
weeks the critical services will get
will get protected uh certainly a case
I'll be making only to wait and see what
the chancellor sets out in this
statement in a couple of weeks time okay
what about the other suggestions the
report says that young people and their
families should be helped out of poverty
beginning with the up rating of family
benefits in line with inflation ending
the two child benefit cap and the
extension of free School meals to all
families receiving Universal Credit
given the severity of the situation will
the government commit to that well let's
just think about the action that's been
taken already to help families with
children and without particularly on
lower income so we've had this energy
crisis families have received families
on Lower incomes this year are receiving
1 200 pounds in help some of that money
is being received this month as we speak
the energy price guarantee is protecting
families from bills that could have been
as high as five or six dollars specific
cases that the reporters and when it
comes to people on Lower incomes you
know we've significantly increased the
minimum wage it's gone from 593 an hour
under labor up to nine pounds 50 now
we've lifted all the tax thresholds so
people on Lower earnings pay no income
tax and no National Insurance whatsoever
so a huge range of measures particularly
designed to help people on Lower incomes
and I'm sure those things are helpful
but what the report is calling for for
an uprating of family benefits in line
with inflation ending the two child
benefit cap and the extension of free
School meals to all families receiving
Universal Credit you can't guarantee
that will I can't because the chancellor
obviously is going to set out his plans
on November 17th he'll have heard that
I'm sure along with other ideas other
people are putting forward as well and
you know we'll find out in a couple of
weeks um what his plans are well we will
indeed there's a lot of focus on that
and I want to talk about the economy a
little bit because
um your old boss Liz truss he worked in
the Treasury under her she said that a
recession wasn't inevitable but we're
now looking at the longest recession in
a century and the decisions that you
made are partly to blame for that aren't
they well I think countries around the
world are facing enormous economic
challenges it's not just this country as
the bank of England said yesterday the
European Central Bank have made similar
comments uh JP Morgan uh said the United
States of America the U.S has similar
challenges the IMF said one-third of
global economies are going to be going
into recession so this is a global
phenomena we're not immune to that but
the UK has a specific problem doesn't it
and in fact asked about whether this
meltdown was down to Global factors
yesterday the bank of England Governor
Andrew Bailey he said I don't really
think that's the case he also has said
that he believed that the mini budget
had damaged the UK standing
internationally you were in the room
when the decisions were made about the
mini budget he's kind of blaming you
isn't he well the decisions uh on around
the mini budget were made by the former
Chancellor and the former you were in
the Prime Minister yeah I was on the
treasury team that's right but the
decisions as you would expect were made
by the chancellor the previous
Chancellor and the previous prime
minister who are no longer in post if
you look at the movements to the
currency and to government bonds that
happened around that time the negative
moves that happened four or five weeks
ago and those numbers have now returned
pretty much to the levels they were
before what we now need to do is uh make
sure that we're on an even Keel the new
Chancellor is doing that already and the
new prime minister Rishi sunak is
someone who successfully guided our
economy through covid we came through
covid uh you know we now have the lowest
unemployment we've had for 48 years
according to the budget an incredible
projection but let's think about where
we're starting from we've got the lowest
unemployment for 48 years because Rishi
sunaka's Chancellor guided us through
covid and I think he'll guide us through
this crisis very well also in terms of
GDP growth um you know last year not
just last year but also this year
according to the IMF the UK had the
highest GDP growth in the G7 not just
last year but this year as well so we
are starting from a good position but in
common with Western economies developed
economies around the world there are
challenges but we can meet them a bit of
recession for for eight quarters
whatever position you start in that's a
pretty bad place to end up and Andrew
Bailey did say that we were hours from
Financial meltdown following the mini
budget are you quite embarrassed to have
been involved in that do you have any
regrets do you feel like you want to
apologize well I think listross has
already apologized and would you would
you reply to us
well although I am along with other
people work was a minister in that
government at the time the decisions
those decisions were taken principally
by the former prime minister to a lesser
extent by the former Chancellor and she
has apologized to that and then neither
of them are in office
um any longer what I think we're doing
now or Jeremy Hunt and we've seen like
you're doing is making sure the country
is on an even Keel and in the same way
that Rishi guided our economy very
successfully through covid you know as I
said we've got the lowest unemployment
for 48 years an incredible achievement
it's half the level that labor left
behind you know I think you'll do the
same thing through this Global crisis
that we're entering if you think about
inflation that is a global crisis you
know uh Eurozone inflation is 10 in
Germany it's 12 in Holland it's 14 so
these are Global problems okay let's
talk about the UK um you talk about the
chancellor being all about sound public
finances we know that cuts are on the
way there are reports this morning that
the new nuclear plant in Suffolk
sizewell C is under review can you
confirm that the case no I'm afraid I
don't know anything about about whether
that is or is not under consideration uh
you know my job in the home office is
looking after policing
um so I can't I can't comment on that at
all I really just don't know
um we'll find out on November 17th um
what the plans are okay well a quick
question then about capital gains tax
the the telegraph reporting of possible
changes any information of the direction
they might be looking at I'm afraid I
just don't know the the treasury will be
making their plans I don't know what
those are and we'll just have to wait
and see what gets announced on the 17th
okay well let's stick to your brief and
which is of course policing as you say
uh Wednesday's damning report found
evidence a poor decision making in
police vetting inconsistent handling of
misconduct cases uh your 2019 Manifesto
set targets 20 000 Police recruitment
cutting Corners to meet those targets no
I don't think so we're on track to meet
that Target by the way we've hired 15
000 of the twenty thousand and we're on
track to deliver all 20 000 extra police
by March of next year by sort of four or
five months time uh three and a half
billion pounds extra was provided to
police forces over that period the 2019
to 2022 period uh when those officers
were being recruited to pay not just for
their additional salaries but also for
the uh the support and the
infrastructure including vetting that
goes around that which makes it
particularly
um sort of disappointing that these very
serious failings were identified by the
inspectors report published a day or two
ago there were 43 recommendations in
that report three of those were for the
home office that we will Implement
um pretty much immediately or certainly
urgently the other 40 recommendations
with police forces
um the npcc uh Chief Martin Hewitt has
said they will act on all of those that
is my expectation as police Minister I'm
going to work with police to make sure
those are implemented as quickly as
possible okay let's talk about Manson
shall we the processing center in Kent
can we get an update on the number of
people that are in that processing
center now how many are there and how
many have been moved out well so uh over
a thousand people have been moved out in
the last uh week or so so a substantial
number uh since the beginning of
September when the current Home
Secretary took office I think a total of
9 000 people if there's people coming in
and out the whole time nine thousand
people have left I think numbers have a
very substantially reduced in the course
of the last week and they're investing
in creating uh more facilities there and
better facilities to address some of the
concerns that have been raised but where
are they gone I mean we've got reports
of a second group of migrants left
stranded at Victoria Coast station well
they've mostly gone to hotels they're
about four and a half thousand uh extra
hotels have been procured but what about
these people that have been stranded yes
there were two groups of people and uh
what I've been told by the uh people on
the immigration side of home office is
that both groups of people had told
immigration officials at manston they
had addresses to go to so friends and
family obviously that turned out
subsequently not to be the case but the
information that Homeless officials had
understood was they had places to go to
because many of the people do have
friends and family in the UK already so
this was a mistake uh yeah well clearly
that without understanding was was not
accurate quite how that misunderstanding
arose maybe was Lost in Translation I
don't know
um but clearly they have now been looked
after okay as a former immigration
compliance Minister do you accept that
manston is not legally compliant now I'm
not sure I do accept that significant
improvements have been made uh recently
we had similar challenges over the
Napier site in folkestone and we made
improvements there to make it compliant
so um you know but we should keep in
mind that you know there is a huge
challenge we've got here with I mean
about 40 000 people so far have
illegally entered the UK so far this
year on small boats and that is a huge
operational challenge it's very very
hard to deal with that now these these
Journeys are totally unnecessary because
France obviously is a safe country with
a well-functioning Asylum system these
Journeys don't need to be made no one is
fleeing war in France these Journeys
should not be made to get be getting
made in the first place well many people
would argue they need more legal routes
to come in and want to talk about the
Asylum Seekers that's right so so first
of all France has a well-functioning
Asylum system secondly the um
predominant nationality the largest
single nationality is Albanian Albania
is a safe and civilized country you
don't need to leave Albania for your
safety it's a safe country in terms of
safe and legal routes we have a lot of
safe and legal routes let me give you a
couple of examples you know we've taken
very briefly 150 000 ukrainians uh 20
000 syrians when there was the war there
23 000 Afghans over a hundred thousand
people from Hong Kong fleeing the
Chinese Communist party we have a lot of
safe and legal routes we've been very
generous to people who are in genuine
need the groups I've just mentioned
being Prime examples of that but we
can't accept and frankly can't even
handle operationally because the numbers
are so large are people making these
dangerous and unnecessary Journeys
across the channel from France a safe
country and that is why quite radical
action is needed legislatively uh to
make sure that our International treaty
obligations aren't being domestically
interpreted okay in a way that makes it
impossible to run our immigrated
immigration systems that we will have to
have another time or conversation to
have another time but I do want to just
come back to this question of whether or
not uh Manson is legally compliant
Robert generic your colleague at tall
Sky News this week he expected Manson to
be returned to a well-functioning and
legally compliant site very rapidly
that's the implication being that it's
not currently legally compliant a lot of
changes have been made in the course of
this week I think Robert has been down
there at least once and possibly twice I
think he's going down again on on Sunday
so significant changes how soon will it
be made before it's legally well I don't
accept the premise that it's not legally
compliant today a lot of changes have
been made even in the last few days
since you spoke to Robert on this chair
I think a few days ago